this year not hunting a lot peace be
with you welcome to the d sharp Eddie
your host and before you go all out red
on Valentine's and you get into the
Valentine's fever you got to watch this
week's show we're going to be discussing
valentine's day and we're also be
talking about miley cyrus Britney Spears
on the D show that's right we're going
to be talking about them connecting it
all together investigating some of these
holidays that we all get in the holiday
spirit with and really find out what's
going on behind the scenes so we'll be
right back with more on these exciting
exciting topics here on the DS show
don't go anywhere
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the danger is the name you know
this is the Salonika creepy to know what
up to LA back on the deep show nazir how
are you my brother I'm did he loud all
praise is due to Allah I'm incredible
you're incredible humble are you look
incredible mashallah all right thank
thank you for any time you know very
important topic and for many people
before they go read because it's all
about love and going red and the
valentines fever we really wanted to
expose people you know the conscious
that God conscious people out there who
really want to live a righteous life we
really want to do the right thing they
kind of sometimes fall into these
pitfalls and they think it's innocent
but really it ends up being a trap so we
want to talk about Valentine's Day you
think you can help us out with this lot
Allah I can really relate to it
obviously being a parent one of the
things that teaching trained parents is
on is really the importance of education
and exposing things as a confidant to
our children in particular because they
tend to be the ones that are more
affected if you will because no matter
what it be what type of holiday what
type of things especially the
Valentine's a thing it tends to focus
around children that's when they start I
remember being in private school and I
went to a Christian private school and
we have Valentine Day parties and mind
you this was a Christian school with the
church I'm saying and study catechism
and all kinds of things but until you
investigate then we just blindly follow
and it's humans we know we don't want to
just blindly follow we want to be
convinced intellectually that what we're
doing is right it actually pleases our
Creator so with valentine day in
particular when it comes to love which
generally is a good thing we think about
love and loving our parents and our
loved ones and things like that those
are things we keep consider close to us
however we know as muslim
that the properly except Aslam reminded
us that Shaitaan has given up all hope
of dealing with us who are tricking us
on the major things so he tends to major
in minor things so it's the little
things that kind of get us and we look
at the Valentine's Day in this
Lupercalia celebration and the things
that went on the things that we wouldn't
be able to say on this show or if you
put into a film it would be above
r-rated if you will and are these things
we have to ask ourselves as parents as
other humans those who care do we really
care enough to investigate one time in
order to find out the truth in order to
change and set a pattern for our family
if need be or are we just going to go go
with the flow you know so so now this is
something that any God conscious person
can relate to doesn't matter if you're
from the Jewish faith or the Christian
faith or just a god-conscious person
after we expose these facts people
should process you know probably have a
change of heart about this whole
valentine so let's go back to the roots
of it how this all started Valentine's
Lupercalia yes well interestingly enough
there are a number of different ways or
number of different myths about how it
started and one of the oldest two tends
to go way back to this big feast in this
big celebration of Lupercalia and it's
interesting because there's the myth of
st. Valentine we're talking shot a lot
about that their God willing you know
about that in a minute but we go back to
a feast that was supposed to be on men
dressing men dressing up in this time in
wolves I believe those wolves clothing
or wolves skins and stuff like that and
they would go they would beat it but the
challenging part is to skip forward to
the story a little bit part of their
celebration they will go and basically
grab women and put into a bowl kind of
like we pick random numbers or random
names they'll go ahead and pick it grab
the women who are supposed to be fertile
in order to continue on their
celebration and just have non-committal
sex and so on and the things that will
follow that of course yeah you know what
I'm saying so just basically some type
of orgy some type of you know sexual
event that pagans used to traditionally
do is and that's one of the reasons
that Christmas was banned even in this
country till the late 1600s it was
actually banned even though hate work on
pagan origins right yes and most of the
things in the days of the week that way
I mean today's Wednesday or wooden's day
if you will which actually has a pagan
you know peg it every day of the week
every month on the calendar not every
month except like the last four at pagan
origins so it's amazing all of these
pagan istic things are around us it's
not a surprise that we take them into
our daily lives and then we blind accept
and follow on holiday without
investigating that we could be on the
wrong path they're doing something
that's displeasing to the Creator so
imagine if you're telling your child hey
you know there's a celebration of
participating in recalling your
Valentine's Day but you know what i want
to do is have some whoop skins go around
take these things beat them and grab
grab a bucket full of someone of the
opposite sex or even the same sex
because that's what happened and go
ahead just be intimate with them but not
really intimate it's just an animalistic
act if you will wouldn't they also now
they would take these because they had
these Roman pagan gods so they also take
these dogs and these wolves and they
would cite this is this actually goes
totally away from the pure monotheism
because now you're worshiping other gods
besides God because these are like these
pagan gods and you're sacrificing these
gods these animals for these pagan gods
now nothing that's indeed and we do it
is amazing because we can look at the
parallels of society some people say oh
well that's old it no longer means that
anymore and say well you know nowadays
it just means this we have to look at
the origin what what it came from and
why is this thing sticking around so
long is that something from us or is it
something from Shaitaan there's
something from the devil you know excuse
me you know we have to ask ourselves
these questions because looking at this
these sacrifice and his blood sacrifice
and these same things there's still
remnants they're still paying some
celebrating to this day but now if you
don't consider yourself a peg in this is
not part of something that you want to
worship we have to ask ourselves why are
we aligned to it why are we allowing our
children to do it why we say oh happy
Valentine's Day why are we being forced
to go out get cards and candy and these
other things that are representative of
the evil and the pagan mystical rituals
that went on at that time it was like
something basically disgusting something
I
in pure and now you put some like
Cologne on and stuff and you want to go
ahead and use it but that doesn't we're
going to be talking more about this we
got to go to break but hopefully this is
going to really enlighten you and you're
going to have a new perspective here on
the Lupercalia Valentine's Day we'll be
right back g had often mistranslated as
holy war the word jihad means to
struggle Islam does not preach violence
it does not preach vicious holy war it
certainly does not condone terror and
suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam order your free copy of the
Koran today werd can't have defects in
it can it if it is literally God's Word
yes it cannot have defects I mean this
was written by men you know that this is
a collection right even if you have
Matthew Mark Luke and John the Gospel
according to according to write the
thing about the Quran and the biggest
and you know i'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is if the quran
is exactly what it says it is and this
doesn't matter whether you're Muslim or
not if the cron is what it says it is
the quran is literally the Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing was told recited right
so if it is literally the word of God
then that's pretty important to me and
before I became Muslim i said if this is
the word of god
then I'm gonna follow it because I'd be
stupid not to I'm not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am Not Afraid of
stand-alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if Allah is by my side I am
not afraid to stay
back here on the Dean show so we touched
upon history a little bit the origins
totally a pagan custom culture something
that where your sacrifice for pagan gods
and any person who's on pure monotheism
he knows that this is something that's
displeasing to the Creator and can can
win you a seat in the Hellfire indeed
indeed because monotheism is something
as pure it's for the Creator and we
don't mess around as pagan and stuff
right so now someone says how lot we're
in modern times I gave the example of
something disgusting and dirty and you
try to put some clone on it I mean is
there anything else you can think of for
someone who brings up this common excuse
it so in it sent its love that was back
then we've basically revamped it what
would you say well one is not to be
naive see one of the challenges is that
as parents I mean I mean we teach of
course that outstanding what's the
parents that we can't be 90 we can't
afford to be naive if we want to look at
investigating something we can we can
literally look one generation in the
past so we may be new parents for
example our children may be young you
know of course if you're an adult
watching this you've been through this
if you already experiencing things I
would about your grandparents and
great-grandparents how has society
changed so if you look at a generation
when I was coming up for example in
fourth and fifth grade even lesser
grades and we're talking about love and
be my valentine have a Valentine Day
candy and being shy and having some high
end that shyness and being nervous my
old girlfriend girls are yucky and boys
are yucky type deal at that age love is
being pushed on us okay do we really
know lover we kept them in love at that
time but let's fast forward to when I
was a teenager ten years later when
hormones are bustling now I'm looking at
girls and not necessarily so yucky girls
are looking at boys and society still
promoting this love fantasy if you will
and that's fast forward even just a few
years later we're now there are
societies and epidemics in certain
cities or across the nation in
particular where you have these
single-family households we have these
unwed teenage moms or unwanted
pregnancies have abortion stuff on the
rise you have poverty that is unable to
really sustain this continual nine
marital relationship in society so but
it comes with an idea this magical
fantasy of this love
you know they pushed our children he
comes off with something as some
innocent and then we can see what the
the negative side effects you have a
doctor PhD and a medical psychologist he
had a really he has a really good book
is called girls on the edge so he talks
about the fourth driving factors for the
new crisis for girls he also has one for
the boys but this one specifically talks
about the for the sexual identity the
cyber bubble the obsessions and the last
one that's very interesting is the
environmental toxins can we classify
this as one of the environmental toxins
along with the other very very important
point sexual identity because you keep
pushing love and you keep pushing this
fake persona of what love should be and
then you have kids coming together
acting out out in the wrong way now you
got all of this sexual deviance and all
the other negative things what you say
on this one well one of the challenges I
mean those four points obviously it hit
it right on the head he hit it right and
then where they come from that because
there are different subs beneath them
however when you think of just sexual
identity in and of itself is an American
devoted an entire epidemic of low
self-esteem and women when it comes to
anorexia and bulimia people that I put
out as models that are supposed to be
the perfect size or these models will
get photoshopped all the time and women
saying oh my skin isn't light enough for
my hair is light of my eyes aren't this
color well I need to get injections in
my face I saw a show recently where
children or teenagers were getting
bullied in school and they were going to
plastic surgeons to actually change
themselves physically I mean is that
really the answer you know so we look at
this and it's not only affected our
children but I grow our baby girls our
daughters and our sisters but grown
women who feel they have to live up to a
standard that's almost impossible to
live up to and not loving themselves and
a body that the Creator has gifted them
with you know while meanwhile they
looked at is toys for the boys they men
aren't physically and drafting changing
themselves to try to appease to some
societal standard however the women are
what does that say for our doesn't how
many like me I have four beautiful
daughters you know I'm not wanting my
daughter to fall prey to the whole
disney princess syndrome where
they're giving this this standard that's
put out by who by people in Hollywood
for example they'd have a huge
homosexual agenda you know there are men
that are the fashion designers but these
are men that don't like women but the
other yet they're the one that are
designing the clothes and things like
that amazing or and they're also
designing clothes that are glittery and
fashion all upon them in all our
disguise of love and just fashion we're
in today's climate you have President
Obama calling the the gay basketball
player and congratulating him with all
the things that are going in the world
he calls to congratulate him about
coming out and recently his wife just
called a potential NFL player about him
you know being possibly being the first
openly gay NFL player like that's an
agenda I've never received a call or
heard anything about hey great for
heterosexuals if you will you know this
is me we treat homosexuals batter or
crazily however there's a huge society
thing going on for those who practice
monotheism we know that if everyone
practice homosexuality end of the human
race so that already lets you know
whether you could weigh in as good or
bad but this agenda starts as a small
seed in something cute in our children
and when we see the results of it
meaning in today's times or as we grow
older and we see what's going on with a
breakdown of the family and divorce
rates skyrocketing over fifty percent
over half of all marriages end in
divorce and two-thirds of people in the
black community for example come from a
single-parent home where the primary
parent is the mother or nowadays when
you have what's considered normal or a
man in a man or a woman in a woman and
they want to raise children the family
we're really creating a serious identity
crisis in the complex that we have to be
addressing and be at the forefront of
addressing the roots of it and it's
these little things of these Valentine
days oh it's all about love well love is
not always good what if you're loving
alcohol what if you're loving in
addiction you know or you're sacrificing
who you are and your identity what you
believe is to get what you think is love
from someone else you know and until we
ask those intelligent questions we can
continue to fall prey to Satan's little
tricks so now we can see the the
negative side effects from what we
perceive as something
sent and then now the bit we have to
look at the bigger picture now is that
what we're looking at so from something
now pure that God created men and women
and they come together in marriage
holistically organically now if we start
from a young age are we saying like
promoting that we're basically promoting
you know boyfriend and girlfriends
coming together outside of marriage and
then we see that like you mentioned
because we know that Islam obviously
came to the way that was sent by the
Creator came to protect mankind and one
of the things that it protects is the
lineage where the family illegitimate
children we also have crime orphans you
know the sexual deviance so if we as
Muslims now we fall into this trap
obviously this is going to end up
affecting us and some of these negative
things are going to have an impact on us
it already is unfortunately I mean we
have Muslim schools where children you
know children are being sent out of the
country because these types of
relationships have infected family only
because we as parents have been naive we
cannot afford to be naive when Shaitaan
is intention to what his troops yeah so
again this is for any God conscious push
person because the Muslim is one who
submits to the will of the Creator so
this is obviously something that Jesus
would it be in line with he wouldn't be
in line probably would someone over
Valentine's Day would he not a not at
all so we'll be right back with more
here on the Dean show
take that simple step that you ask your
maker to guide you that he'll guide you
yes I advise this a lot so for people
researching put your head on the floor
and in the in the state of prostration
like all the prophets good and ask the
creator of the universe to show me the
way to guide you to the straight path
and someone who sincerely ask for guided
if there is something there eat some
things were you mad man watch the show
the deed show back here on the D show
we're discussing the Lupercalia
valentine's day something that we
perceive as innocent before we go all
red and before some of the even the
sisters they go and put on the redhead
jobs you can stop stop right there huh
so we talked about a little bit of the
origins and some of the negative side
effects that can end up coming and we
know that this way of life that was sent
for all of mankind is a mercy protects
us help us to see straight another
innocent thing or something that people
perceive as innocent is let's say we've
mentioned miley cyrus britney spears and
many of the other dozens of dozens of
superstars that they come their roots
are from the disney channel so let's
talk about a little bit of the disney
channel because some youth are addicted
to the disney channel some parents they
think is innocent what's the big deal
disney channel well Mickey Mouse yeah
Mickey Mouse see subhanAllah it's
amazing that these little things can
make such a big difference for example
with Disney when we look at Snow White
what's the premise of its no way she'd
been to his apple fell asleep in some
Prince Charming had to come and save her
and kiss her were they married knows
tomorrow yes it was the woman week yes
need to be saved by a man yes it
promotes this weakness of women where we
don't come from that is long we have
scholarship of women look at Aisha
already long and huh she was a fourth
highest narrator of hadith the
Companions would come to her and ask her
about different narrations to study from
her you know when the first as at a
school in North Africa was I believe
Fatima don't remember her name the study
you know establish school in Islam so
our women come from a period of strength
if you will nevertheless we would look
at Snow White's you look at Cinderella
for example going out and kicking it at
a big party and losing her glass Xuan
coming to be swept up by this man it
really creates an idea of dependency and
this fantasy man is going to come in
straight it and figure it all out for
you whether or not he may already
married or he may be doing something or
you're not married and not looking for
marriage this fantasy arises and when
you talked about Miley Cyrus who was
previously was Hannah Montana little
girl show doing little girl things and
now she got turned I'm not she's Miley
Cyrus and twerking controversy and just
trash is what it comes to this is a
process it was not accidental didn't I
would be interesting if it's just one
person maybe then you have Britney
Spears we see her Mickey Mouse stuff
little cute gir attracting millions of
fans within as soon as that teenage
years come so the bodies begin to
develop now I'm so she taking off her
clothes promiscuous and drugged out
everything else then you have Christina
Aguilera she's again Disney Channel
smart little girl creating this
following of millions of girls who are
now women then actually no she's in the
video dirty taking off her clothes and
having chaps on it's amazing then you
have even boys on the other side you
have shia labeouf what's that a song
dirty dirty scar dirty yeah they're
letting you know clearly what it is you
know so you to go from here to this
transition to being promiscuous cutting
your changing your entire look
advocating alcohol and artists / sex if
you will come in looking for love and
looking for something hints we have the
drinking you have the alcohol abuse you
have all this stuff because there's an
emptiness inside of them that are comedy
like aslam fulfills and provide you with
and it doesn't require that you sell
yourself short and the value of women is
not put in
and their skin and how much they could
show us toys for men you know the cover
that up and they keep that and protect
that and actually be forced to have
someone deal with you for your mind when
all I can see is your face I mean
everything is coupled reset my hands in
my face you know what I'm saying there's
not a protest about that whether or not
I'm being oppressed but when our women
do it as most of women is the Virgin
Mary covered for example many times
looked at is being oppressed for some
reason but you would only look at such a
righteous woman to hear what she has to
say with some of the wisdom and
god-fearing this if you will yeah that
doesn't make sense because if they were
oppressed I mean they're they're being
more pressed for wanting to cover by
their by the you know all the negative
media comments and but they're fighting
for is their choice so you made actually
a comment you said it crushes the
woman's self-esteem because all of it is
about the outer beauty and the booty the
booty booty you can you say that on the
Dean show the booty here we go sterile
Dean show and actually get into what the
word means or where it comes so you're
saying now that it's big it lowers her
self-esteem and it becomes every it's
all about her outer not inner and heard
beauty that's all they're looking at not
really concentrate on the inner and and
and so you think of a Valentine's Day
for example it's about having a
Valentine what does that Valentine oh
this is my love this is my sweet this is
my thing if you will and of course it's
about the beauty it's about the outer
beauty and attracting there's not about
marriage it's not about wars are not
about proposals though many people
proposed on the day which is very
unoriginal but it's about that in you
asked about booty well what is booty
booty is defined as treasurer or spoils
of war this is what what happened after
war this is it is not Valentine's Day a
war on our morals so that's that man
he's just wanting to conquer that woman
for his self pleasure like like Cupid
actually Cupid I believe means desire so
that's another also another a pagan god
is actually gets actually isn't it
indeed indeed and he's you know what I
know what his arrow because look at his
love this little cherub going around but
is it goes right back to capturing that
treasure yeah that booty that what that
spoils of war if you will to the point
where now that's the part that's twerked
or that's the part that's put out in
front of people on a woman you know I'm
saying is this what we want for our
daughters or our society is this what
we're really going to promote to be
something that's healthy and something
that's righteous so that's going to get
you where you go even when you have a
myth I mentioned and we have to say it
because I mentioned earlier about st.
Valentine this whole myth that he was
performing these marriages was actually
a good thing performing these marriages
and was getting locked up and stuff
forward and they were passing cards
which was the origin supposedly of
Valentine Day cards well think about it
when it comes to a marriage when it
comes to being more on and being in
family and strengthening society that's
something that's done within your
religious class or within your own
community it's something that should be
protected not something that's someone
should be locked up for or you create a
story to try to justify it and create
another fantasy again because it's a
myth when the reality goes into this
pagan ritual so we have to recognize
number one is this okay with me have I
investigated have I studied it and if it
is okay with you why if it's not okay
with you why but we just again want to
call you to the Dean according to the
truth so you can separate any and
everything that is falsehood and only be
with the one thing that is true before
we cut out also attaching your heart to
a lot of these superstars now as a young
child you have your kid watching this
Disney Channel and getting all their
heart attached to him say miley Hannah
Montana for instance now she gets older
and obviously the heart it's you know
it's attached to this person is a good
chance now Hannah Montana now she's my
Miley Cyrus she's out there basically
you know showing at all drugs alcohol
just basically destroying her life
there's a good chance your choice of
Europa millions are gonna come with him
is that absolutely probability she
hasn't lost fans they just got an older
yeah and now if you want to see who's
gonna be the future stars look at the
Disney Channel look at your daughter's
following now and let's see what they'll
be in five or ten years as starts
because we already have the pattern we
know what's going to happen yeah is that
okay is that what you want for your
girls that the type of woman you want
for your boys to be desiring and we're
seeing right now people can see many of
the the the pictures are showing a lot
of these stars getting arrested for
drugs for alcohol intoxication and these
are these young stars that people are
looking up to so
hopefully God willing we can benefit
from this and really live a good
wholesome life that's pleasing to the
crater before we meet our Creator
because definitely this way that way is
the wrong way to go what would you have
to say no indeed one hundred percent
it's our responsibility as parents
matter of fact I'd like to give a gift
to all the viewers that our parents a
book that I author called Muslims
parenting on purpose so you can actually
send it to you for free just have to pay
for shipping go to outstanding Muslim
parents.com / Dean show and you can get
it from there in sha allah jazak allah
hi thank you very much why y'all come
okay thank you peace be with you and
meet likewise and thank you for tuning
in to the D show and hopefully you ain't
gonna go read it's nothing wrong with
the color red but hopefully now about
times around and you've changed you have
a totally new perspective now on really
what you should be doing and not falling
into these pitfalls of Shaitaan and the
women now we talked about who want to
live a life of integrity of dignity of
modesty not wanting to follow Lady Gaga
googoo wanting to follow Mary the mother
of Jesus that's the Muslim woman the one
who's chosen to submit not to her
desires not to the peer pressure of
society but to the Creator the one who
created all of mankind and that is what
we're calling you to that's the purpose
of life to acknowledge that now you have
a creator he created you you get up and
clap when somebody hits a nice free
throw jump shot 3-pointer right someone
writes a nice song you're all like out
of your mind but what about the one who
created you who made you don't you
acknowledge that will start to ask him
because if you've been led to the Dean
show that's a good chance now that the
process is started but are you going to
deny all these signs start asking the
crater earnestly to guide you and keep
coming back to the Dean show and if you
have any suggestions any questions
please follow us you've seen some of
these pictures that we've come up put up
with a good message positive message you
can take these and share them you get
them at our Facebook page you can also
follow us on Twitter stay in contact
with us and hopefully this time of year
you could be with positive people so you
can have a positive outcome and then get
to Jenna paradise because that's what
we're striving for for the pleasure of
our Creator and then for
or the eternal delights of paradise and
avoiding the Hellfire this is what Jesus
taught and all the messages of God
including the last final messenger
problem homme and peace be upon them
we'll see you next time peace be with
you